hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
how are you guys doing I recently came
across a video where Joe Rogan is having
a discussion with a UFC middleweight
Contender Sean Strickland and Sean
Strickland is giving his anecdotal
experience of his experience with some
Muslim fires maybe from chechny or
Dagestan or something like this in his
gym let's take a look at the clip and
come back and respond in kind I make fun
of everybody
so there is a guy named Albert we have a
lot of Muslims at the gym love these
guys so one day Albert derov comes up to
me and he was like hey Sean can I talk
to you I thought he's gonna show me a
move I'm like all right sure I'll be
your wrestling dummy fruit and all these
little Muslims come in the cage before
we didn't guard what position are we in
here Albert he's like no no no no sit
down sit down
puts his hand on my leg Muslim dude are
super touchy they're friendly super
friendly guys so odd especially because
of religion so it's like Sean Sean Sean
in my country I cannot be friends with
you I'm like what are you talking about
he's like you say things about Islam
pretty much saying I cannot be friends
with you because what you say about
Islam right I've never I mean I'd make
fun of Jews Christians scientologists so
after that after he Crest my leg and rub
my head a little bit I was like okay
dude I'm gonna lay off Islam now what
this clip shows us is that the
importance of establishing great
boundaries I'd be watching Joe Rogan
for some time now I think many of you
have as well and we've seen his
attitudes change and shift right towards
Islam and Muslims over the last half
decade
and it's very this shows you that when
we as the Muslim Community show other
people other communities uh other
influences whatever it may be what our
red lines are
then people eventually respect those red
lines we are a force to be reckoned with
remember we are core of the world's
population going to be a third of the
world's population by the end of the
century according to Pew research so yes
we are forced to be reckoned with people
want to have a proper functional life in
this in this globalized world it makes
sense for them to respect our boundaries
and that's what we've achieved here
that's why I respect those guys that
done what they've done with Sean
Strickland and in fact uh this is
exactly the Islamic position you know
you cannot be a friend with somebody who
attacks the prophet Muhammad sallam and
who uh besmerches the sacred symbols of
Islam it's kind of like what Malcolm X
said famously said that a man
who Falls
for or stands for nothing a man who
stands for nothing will fall for
anything
you see a man with no boundaries a
community With No Boundaries a people
with no boundaries are no people at all
and the Quran is completely filled with
ayat
verses
which indicate the importance of Mighty
mightiness and self-dignity for example
is
that all you who believe if you go back
on your heels and apostate then I'll
replace you with the people who are
Mighty with the mighty with the
disbelievers humble with the Believers
that they struggle in the path of Allah
and they don't care about the blame of
the blamers they don't care too much
about these people what they're going to
say or what these guys we're not trying
we're not here to appease
the other communities like that and in
fact the more you try and appease and
placate and acquiesce to other
communities and other people the more
they will see you
as uh lacking in Dignity of someone that
they can play around with so we must
maintain our dignity as the Muslim
Community as the Quran States in regards
to this kind of very important thing
which uh famous Ayah was which Allah
says
he will not find somebody yes who really
believes in Allah in the last day
being so loving with those who oppose
Allah to his messenger even if
even if they were their fathers or their
brothers or their extended families or
whatever
that's it you will not find you will not
find it if you're truly yeah believe in
Allah is Messenger someone who's
opposing that yeah you cannot be their
friend and start loving them and showing
them it's not dawah that's not how to be
a proper dignified person in Islamic
tradition we don't care what you think
of us we don't care if you don't like
that we don't really care about that you
know what I mean we've got our own thing
going on if you respect us and you
respect the Muslim Community yeah we
will return that energy that positive
energy of positive energy but if you
disrespect the Muslim Community yeah we
will disrespect you simple as that
Noah he said that if you're gonna make
fun of us we're going to make fun of you
like you make fun of us
so if you make fun of us yeah if you
disrespect us if you disrespect the holy
prophet Muhammad you disrespect Islam
now you're disrespecting us we don't
want to be your friend we're not on that
kind of thing we're not interested but
if you want to be respectful then yeah
we're going to be respectful to you as
well that is the Islamic position on the
matter
the prophet Muhammad
sallam told us but whoever builds a
mosque for Allah Allah will build for
him a Sim at the house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death whenever
someone prays there whenever someone
gives shahada in the Masjid whenever
someone learns something in the Masjid
yes that will be something that you'll
have on your scale